on est dans le pays de la bouche en plus
on est vraiment l'aube et la gastronomie
c'est pas ici qui va mourir des gens
bien c'était le 26 septembre 1985 en
direct à la radio
coluche appel à la solidarité les
restaurants du coeur sont nés très vite
des équipes se mobilisent partout en
france des étudiants en école de
commerce et des chômeurs bénévoles se
chargent de l'organisation comme ici à
reims étant au chômage maintenant je
peux le bricolage tous les jours mais ça
c'est pas grand chose alors comme
j'étais artisan dans le transport j'ai
encore des camions je remettais à sa
disposition gratuitement
à l'époque la france connaît un chômage
de masse des familles entières se
retrouvent sans ressource
c'est ce qu'on appelle les nouveaux
pauvres face à cette situation
coluche parcourt la france pour
promouvoir son association première
destination l'île où il est accueilli à
bras ouverts par le maire pierre mauroy
on a besoin concrètement de services
municipaux dans le genre locaux pour que
vous voulez créer un restaurant c'est
plutôt un endroit de passage
après lille connus seront à bordeaux
puis toulouse et après des semaines
d'organisation c'est l'heure du grand
lancement pour les restos du coeur ça y
est les restaurants du coeur commence le
21 décembre 1985 700 bénévoles
s'affairent dans 18 villes pour
distribuer des repas on en a 18 je veux
vous dire une liste de deux villes enfin
importante l'île dans la région du nord
on va faire aujourd'hui on va distribuer
4000 repas c'est là où on a le plus gros
effort bordeaux évidemment toulouse
amiens marseille le havre lyon enfin
voilà dix-huit villes en france ont
ouverte aujourd'hui
parmi ces villes gennevilliers en région
parisienne plusieurs centaines de repas
sont distribués sous un chapiteau dressé
pour l'occasion c'est quoi ta télé
coluche lui-même s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement vingt bénévoles mais
aussi des entreprises et d'autres
associations sont venues apporter leur
aide
tous ceux qui ont faim ils faut qu'ils
manche et c'est ce qui m'a séduit dans
les dites que le ch avec cet énorme
publicité
j'espère que ça va faire bouger un peu
les français qui sont quelquefois un peu
égoïste mais dès qu'on leur demande
quelque chose ça marche formidablement
au total 5000 bénévoles ont distribué
8.5 millions de repas pour cette
première édition en 1985
aujourd'hui les restos du coeur sont
plus que jamais mobilisés en 2019
ce sont plus de 133 millions de repas
qui ont été distribués par l'association
[Musique]